the jurogan experience listen
it was a long time coming it's it's it's
just
i'm happy that it happened now because
if i if it didn't happen it would have
been something else i would have been in
a grave
yeah or somewhere else who the hell
knows where they would have put me when
did you start
i've been i've been fat my whole life
i've been thinking about losing weight
for a long time for about
30 years but when did you start losing
weight when last march
last march so right around the pandemic
literally right when it hit
my brand new baby and my wife they were
gonna go to columbia to show the child
you know you have to show the child to
the family and
it was around march 10th we get to the
airport
some state they wouldn't let my dog get
on the plane cause they didn't have the
air conditioning didn't work in the in
the galley or whatever that is
so we turned right back around and went
home and that's the day [ __ ] hit the fan
i was supposed to go on tour a week
right after that
everything done i knew it was all gonna
be done
i was talking to my agent he was like
yeah this shit's gonna be fine don't
worry they're gonna still do the show in
hawaii i was like nah watch this shit's
gonna be [ __ ] done
so bottom line why'd you think
everything was gonna get shut down i
don't know
i had a feeling i just have a [ __ ] i had
a feeling that this was just bigger than
what it was
you know than just it just seemed fishy
just seemed
fishy yeah so pretty much i mean
to get the dog onto the plane we had to
put her on the scale because she was a
little overweight
what's overweight for a dog i'm not
really sure i think she looks great
what is overweight for a dog though how
do they decide that like i used to have
a dog that was 140 pounds this is
overweight
i don't think so it's just jacked this
isn't it
that's all i think if you're at a
certain we just this dog is an english
setter
supposed to have a little waste and
listen she lost it a little bit she lost
herself she's living in brooklyn now you
know she's not
back where she's from exercising exactly
it's different yeah
she's eating different foods right her
metabolism changed
so i don't blame her so
i i definitely better i feel her and
then
i started losing weight because of her
because we both got on the scale
and i was like what the [ __ ] is going on
what was the highest
380 something oh yeah [ __ ]
it was despicable i didn't look it
though
i looked about 3.50
a [ __ ] round ball of [ __ ] meat a
meatball
yeah that was a [ __ ] meatball what
was your health like like what did you
what did it feel like walking around
like that because that's
this is the thing man um people love to
talk about like fat
shaming yeah and i know it's not good to
make people feel bad but you have to
but that you have to shame me i was
shamed into this for sure it's
unfortunate
that you have to make people feel bad to
start getting them to change but
sometimes
whether it's a person doing that to you
or you just looking in the mirror and
you're feeling bad
that that feeling is just reality that's
what that feeling is
like you can't fat shame a skinny you
can't fat shame jamie no
he's not fat right so if you said hey
jamie you're fat like it doesn't work it
doesn't mean
anything it only means something when
it's real and
it's an indulgence thing it's not it's
it's not a thing that you can't control
it's a hard thing to control it's a hard
thing to bounce back from and that's
what i'm most impressed with you
you've you've really bounced back you've
lost 130 [ __ ] pounds man
and we we had a good workout today we
went over to the honor gym
shout out to my man john wolfe john
wolf's the master i love him how good is
he i mean
i i've watched him and now that i met
him it's like
all the pieces came together today for
me he's one of the most knowledgeable
trainers i've ever worked with in my
life he's amazing he
and it's not just like meathead stuff
it's all about mobility and
flexibility there's no nothing nothing i
mean you can obviously lift a lot of
weight
yeah he showed us he could do the 106
overhead press with not like nothing
yeah but it ain't about that it's about
being able to it's fluidity it's about
to be
it's about using your body and using
your muscles in a functional manner
yeah not just he's all about
longevity and he's all about range of
motion his whole thing is about
having you have like the full mobility
of your body it's all
these flexibility things we did the hip
things that we did all that stuff and
it's all to strengthen the joints
stabilize your shoulders stabilize
all your joints and he's he's just so
good so the pre-workout that we did
yeah soaked i was stuck before we
started
it was great it's unbelievable you're
very strong though man you're really
strong
it was it was interesting to watch you
do it like i can see like over this past
year you know you've gotten your body to
a really good place where
you know you haven't just lost weight by
dieting you've been lifting weights
you've been
exercising and pushing sleds and i watch
your instagram man you're doing some
wild [ __ ] for sure
i mean i these are the things that i
always wanted to do i always knew i
could do this i played football in high
school and i actually
i excelled in practice like i liked
doing that [ __ ] i like drills i like
having an
aim the game yeah it's fun but i like
the practice stuff
right what i mean yeah yeah and i
started losing weight by myself in my
house
literally during the pandemic just
eating different my wife
she was shaming me because yes she was
because we have a brand new child she's
like what the [ __ ] you doing you want to
be around here for our baby like you
you want to take yourself away from us
right
and that [ __ ] hit that's real it hit
hard that's a real thing
and not only that like i love life
there's no doubt about it i've
i've been going so fast for the past 10
years that i haven't really enjoyed
myself so this
force this forced stoppage allowed me to
really reassess
my happiness and i've regained
everything you know it's not just
[ __ ]
work work work next thing next thing
next thing of course i'm an artist and
my mind is always all over the place i'm
always thinking about
something you know but this slowed me
down
it allowed me to spend every moment with
my brand new child
you know yeah it's it's [ __ ] it was
something that i didn't know i needed
but i
needed that yeah i needed it and and to
regain
my health like in this in this manner
man it's like you said
i wasn't i don't want to just lose
weight
people could get the surgeries and all
that [ __ ] that ain't for me
i'm a worker the problem with i like
hard work
the surgery can help people but it also
it messes you up and here one of the
things that happens
it diminishes your ability to absorb
food you can't have as much food
and it's harder for you to absorb
nutrients i would never do that yeah i
was just never in my cards
it was never for me good for you yeah
hell no that because i knew
i did this to myself yeah i have to fix
it yeah and i'm dedicated you know
like i was talking to my boy like me and
cece sabathia were friends
and i was talking to him for a while we
would just text back and forth because
he was a fat bastard too
and he changed his [ __ ] up and we would
just talk about how we want to be
[ __ ] jacked we just want to be
but we want to get you know strong and
[ __ ] and he put me on to my trainer that
i was working with dave palladino
and dave is kind of you know he's like
an old-school meathead from the jersey
shore and i [ __ ] love that
so we clicked yeah because it could have
met somebody else and it wouldn't have
clicked
right you know like i've worked out with
other people but it just wasn't i almost
don't want to let him down you know
right like he's a [ __ ] like he's in the
sopranos or some [ __ ] i swear
it's maybe it's in my mind but i have to
but it works that way
right yeah he was showing me all he's
like [ __ ] joey diaz
but jacked i swear that's who he is
that's what i was thinking about i
was like yo that's who this [ __ ] guy
is
exactly him he has the stories of the
shore he used to bounce all the clubs
with the [ __ ] fanny pack and the
[ __ ] i don't want to mention what
else but you know
listen he he put me on to different
types of training he didn't just start
me off with meathead stuff
we did the sleds we did the torturous
[ __ ] the skier
the [ __ ] all that the stepper oh my
god the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is torture but i love it catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience